you are watching TV
[Music]
you
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
in the world today there's a growing
shift towards renewable energy such as
solar and wind because of this shift
there needs to be a way to store the
energy received to be released later
when the Sun isn't shining or the wind
isn't blowing on this channel we've
already covered Tesla's ground energy
storage plans for their utility battery
power pack systems so far to
successfully power kawaii and Island on
Hawaii using solar energy and battery
storage systems Tesla also installing
systems in South Australia to sort out
their power troubles and more Tesla
power packs are set to be installed in
New South Wales as well these solutions
are all based on lithium-ion technology
in just the previous episode we've seen
how the underlying technologies of
lithium-ion batteries are improving the
charging speed is drastically increasing
along with the long term cycle battery
life the same is true for energy density
in addition on a utility scale battery
technology does have the distinct
advantage of a rapid install time and a
rapid response time to energy
fluctuation needs but despite all of
this when it comes to the application of
utility energy storage there are still
some questions namely the long-term cost
and the real long term battery cycle
life in terms of current generation
batteries as you'll soon see there's
another energy storage method that's a
pretty interesting take on the problem
at hand it involves the storage and
release of energy using mountains as
natural pressure vessels this method
achieved by the company alec is promises
relatively low cost and high efficiency
in this video we'll take a look as a
side point this isn't responsive video
and I wasn't paid for any of this I just
like to search out innovations that I
think is interesting so let's get into
it
in a nutshell energy storage solutions
like alec aids is planning to do an
attempt to smooth out the fluctuations
in electricity production due to the
nature of renewable energy I had the
privilege of meeting gives Ana the man
in charge of this project while I was in
Switzerland I've invited him to talk
about his technology and how it fits
into the current backdrop of energy
needs unfortunately for this interview
the sound of my side wasn't working but
there's still a lot of valuable
information here my name is Diana and
I'm the managing director of alec i
which is a company based in switzerland
in to develop a new kind of storage
technology so electricity storage
technology that is aimed at storing
large amounts of energy
so you basically when you have a lot of
renewable energy in the mix and in your
electricity grid due to the
intermittency of these sources which
means unpredictability so you don't know
when the Sun is attacking dimension how
much how much the wind is going to close
when you have a lot of these kind of
sources in the energy mix you want to
have a way to compensate these
fluctuation and the story acknowledges
we're working on is this method that can
with low cost and the relatively high
efficiency be one of these the key
components for at risk that is run on
renewable energy so how does it work
basically the system uses excess energy
from the grid to pump pressurized air
into a cavity within the mountain the
air is then cooled down using
specialized technology called thermal
energy storage and then stored within
the pressure cavity when it's time to
generate electricity this air is then
heated up again and pushed out to run a
turbine that produces electricity with
this system alec eyes claim over 72%
round trip efficiency
in our interview give mentions that
although geology has to be taken into
account the markets that would be suited
for this technology include the
continent of Europe America Canada but
especially India and China for those
last two markets looking at recent
trends it's not hard to see why they
would be a fit these two countries have
had very aggressive goals and providing
renewable energy to help run their
country's infrastructure to give you an
idea by 2027 India is aiming for 60
percent of its energy to be provided by
sources outside of fossil fuels
meanwhile in China they've decreased
their coal usage by five percent
year-over-year and have just overtaken
the United States as a leader in
renewable energy and with populations of
about 1.3 billion apiece that's a huge
market for electricity storage solutions
for renewable energy let me just say why
we need the mountain is them you need a
container to store a fist or press right
there you probably know like even from
small gas containers to use for either
not doing picnic or providing the gas
port for cooking as it's a small compare
that has a pressurized gas in it however
if you want if it's a small container is
reasonably easy and cheap to do but if
you want to have a very large container
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of cubic meters of air it is
unable to make a student feel container
to hold that or any other kind of
something so basically that's why we
want to exploit the geology and then the
ways of the mountains awake of the earth
to contain contain deserts is there
[Music]
in 2016 the company completed their
first pilot plant located in the Swiss
Alps the plant is the shape of a 120
meter long and five meter diameter
tunnel with an energy capacity of one
megawatt hour the Swiss Federal Office
of Energy Finance 40% of the cost of the
plan as they could see a benefit to the
country from this kind of technology
[Music]
give states that economically mechanical
storage that uses compressed air is
still cheaper than batteries the tools
and machinery have been around for a
long time and right now the technology
is of a factor of four to six times less
than batteries on a per kilowatt-hour
scale however the falling cost of
batteries are a risk and the company
would be keeping an eye on that under
the day nobility part there's a couple
of interesting studies that look at
actually how much energy you can store
in source device compared to how much
energy was used to create that storage
device so actually for battery system I
am you can now store 10 times the amount
of energy that you use to make the
battery during the whole lifetime of it
and with compressed air it's 260 times
so there's a huge difference in
something that needs to be kept in mind
if you want to have a general grid that
is sustainable also in the long term
otherwise if you have to every 10 times
that you use damage to create it you
need to change it you can you can you
can think about it will also have
ecological problems or symbols problems
yeah well actually it has been used
before so there are two plants already
running in the world one of them is in
Germany for killing 79 even and the
other one is in is in the USA in Alabama
it's what is in 91 boaters can use salt
caverns on the ground they basically dig
on the ground your big soil formation
and they compress the air there there
are two problems with that one of them
is that which I didn't mention before
which is quite unfortunate when you
compress the air it naturally heat up
this is about phenomenon we have
experience with a bicycle pump when the
you wanna give when you pump the tire is
you feel at the comfort warming up so
this is happen that much stronger extent
when you're working with higher pressure
and this he needs to be needs to be also
kind of stored because it can be up to
60% of the energy that you use to
compress the air and these plans that
exist don't use the sender you don't use
this energy don't use the heat they just
discard it and then when they need to
expand here against produces electricity
they use gas burners so it has goals
with reducing co2 it goes with the
reduction efficiency and so on and so
forth and the reason for that is that at
the time there were not machines who
were able to also kind of store the heat
or is it the heat that is produced
during the compression so they were
cooled down to kind of protect the
machine and this has now changed so the
machine your machinery is available that
you can use to compress at the same time
also reduce the heat that is that is
being created and we what we do is we
have then one component inside of our
cavern which is called the thermal
storage which then stores all of it each
and gives it back to the air when we are
going to expand it and like this as you
don't need the gas burning anymore so we
don't have the co2 emissions and they
are much higher efficiencies that we
have lower cost and this has also come
true partially due to technology the
development meter in
in the last decade let's talk about
costs so according to give it costs
about 100 million 200 million u.s.
dollars for about 200 to 500 megawatt
hours output but the larger the scale of
the project and more it makes sense and
it becomes more value for money this
kind of technology is really something
that a small start-up or a set of
consultants can tackle aleck eyes are
targeting big institutions as partners
for new projects so I guess that's about
it so I want to thank give for coming on
cold fusion and talking with us and I
also want to thank you for paying
attention and watching through the whole
video I hope you learn something
interesting and in a wider kind of way
it kind of shows that you can't really
just throw renewable energy out the
window saying that it's not going to
work there are a lot of people working
on different ways to make the technology
more feasible right now today so anyway
thanks for watching this has been the
Geiger you've been watching cold fusion
if you just stumbled across this channel
feel free to subscribe cheers guys and
I'll see you again soon for the next
everyone
Oh
[Music]